This is 99 per se invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the west coast of Ireland, on the banks of an estuary dividing county Limerick from County Claire, lies a small town called Shannon. But Shannon is not a quaint fishing village or a farming community. Its industry is its airport, and Shannon Airport is big. It handles up to 1.7 million passengers and 20,000 flights a year. Most of them from other countries.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在爱尔兰西海岸，利默里克郡与克莱尔郡交界的一处河口岸边，坐落着一个小镇，名叫香农。但香农并非风景优美的渔村或农业社区。这里的支柱产业是它的机场，而香农机场规模很大。它每年接待多达170万名旅客和2万架次航班。其中大多数来自其他国家。
And a few months ago, I went to visit. That's reporter Kevin Canner's. When you arrive at the airport, you're greeted by a modern looking building that's sleek and black. And when you enter through the sliding doors and step into the check-in area, you find yourself in a bright grand atrium with wooden furnishings and tall ceilings. It's a style that you might call international terminal chic. Everything attests to a certain kind of reassuring cosmopolitan competence. But my reason for entering the terminal wasn't to catch a flight to
几个月前，我去进行了参观。这是记者凯文·卡纳尔的报道。当你抵达机场时，迎接你的是一座外观现代、线条流畅且呈黑色的建筑。当你推开滑动门，步入值机大厅时，你会发现自己身处一个明亮宏伟的中庭，这里有木质陈设和高耸的天花板。这是一种你可以称之为“国际航站楼时髦风”的风格。一切都彰显出某种令人安心的国际化专业素养。但我进入航站楼的原因并不是为了赶去
Mallorca or Warsaw or to pick up a friend. It was to visit its duty free shop. Okay, and this is it? The 2D free shop? Yeah, we're in our 2D free shop here in China Airport. The world's first airport 2D free shop. The fact is the first 2D free shop. We take pride in it. It's unique, it's ours, and it always will be ours. That's now Molloni, the airport operation and commercial director, showing me around. The shop is what you'd expect from a duty free,
马略卡岛或华沙，也不是为了去接朋友。而是为了参观它的免税店。好的，这就是吗？2D免税店？是的，我们现在身处香农机场的2D免税店。这是全球第一家机场2D免税店。事实上，这是第一家2D免税店。我们为此感到骄傲。它是独特的，是属于我们的，而且永远属于我们的。这是机场运营和商业总监诺尔·莫洛尼在带我参观。这家店正如你对免税店的期望一样，
stocked with designer perfumes, jewelry, and various fine foods. And for us as in the airport, it's also what promoting Irish products. So water crystals, you know, food company or sweet shop brands and all that. It's about actually trying to support local industry as well as probably the more well-known brands. There are Guinness branded t-shirts and baseball caps, green children's clothes covered with shamrocks, knitted sweaters, and of course lots of whiskey. What I might do is I might ask Alan here, gonna talk about a whiskey bag? I could, Alan, I couldn't talk to you for two minutes.
里面摆满了设计师香水、珠宝和各种精选食品。对我们机场而言，这也是为了推广爱尔兰产品。比如沃特福德水晶，你知道的，食品公司或糖果店品牌等等。这其实是为了支持本土产业以及那些可能更知名的品牌。这里有健力士品牌的T恤和棒球帽、印有三叶草图案的绿色儿童服装、针织毛衣，当然还有大量的威士忌。我接下来要做的是，我可能会请教这里的艾伦，谈谈威士忌包？我可以的，艾伦，我能跟你聊两分钟吗？
I kept me here a few minutes pro, I'm quite juicy free yet. And naturally, I wanted to make sure I took full advantage of the situation, courtesy of 99PI. I was actually told by the podcast production that I could buy one as a business expense. Wait, we did what? So if you have any recommendations. I can recommend you just tell me how big your budget is and I'll help you spend it. Well, I'm not paying for it, so...
我在这里留了几分钟，而且我还没怎么逛免税店呢。自然地顶着99PI的光环，我想确保自己充分利用了这次机会。播客制作组实际上告诉过我，我可以买一件作为业务开销。等等，我们什么时候说过？所以如果你有什么推荐的话。我可以推荐，你只要告诉我你的预算是多少，我来帮你想办法花掉。好吧，又不用我花钱，所以……
Whoa, whoa, whoa, how much did you spend? It's not important. What's important is the reason I came here. Because it turns out that this first-ever airport duty free is the brainchild of a remarkable person, a local boy from right near Shannon, who would go on to change both Ireland and the world in some really unexpected ways, not just by hawking cheap booze, but by helping revolutionize how entire countries think about the idea of selling and buying things. Tax-free Before the airport arrived, there wasn't much in Shannon. There wasn't even a town called Shannon for anything to be in. just some swampy marshland alongside
哇，哇，哇，你花了多少钱？这不重要。重要的是我来这里的目的。因为事实证明，这家史上第一家机场免税店是一位杰出人物的心血结晶，他是一个土生土长的香农本地男孩，后来以一些真正出人意料的方式改变了爱尔兰乃至全世界，他不仅仅是通过兜售廉价酒，而是通过彻底变革整个国家对买卖商品这一概念的看法。免税在这座机场出现之前，香农并没有什么东西。甚至连一个叫香农的镇子都没有，所以无所谓里面有什么。只有沿岸
the estuary of the river Shannon. But if the region wasn't exactly a center of commerce and industry, the same could be said for much of Ireland. The Irish restate, as it was first known, gained independence from Britain in 1922. But for a long time, independence did not equal prosperity. The New Irish state, it was independence in theory, but in reality it was still a naft shoes of the British economy. Brian Callanan is the author of Ireland's Shannon Story.
香农河口的沼泽地。但如果该地区算不上商业和工业中心的话，爱尔兰的大部分地区也是如此。爱尔兰自由邦（正如它最初为人所知的那样）于1922年获得了对英国的独立。但长期以来，独立并不等于繁荣。新的爱尔兰国家，名义上是独立的，但在现实中它仍然受到英国经济的摆布。布莱恩·卡拉南是《爱尔兰的香农故事》一书的作者。
And Brian says that after independence, the Irish economy was still reeling from centuries of colonization, during which Ireland had one job to produce cattle and crops for Britain. Any native Irish industry had been actively discouraged by the British to prevent competition. So well into the 20th century, when much of the rest of Europe was busy urbanizing and industrializing, Ireland was still a mostly agrarian country that exported little, besides food. Say in the 1950s, something like 40% of the world's 50% of those shares would have been involved in agriculture, were raised enterprise. Wow, that's pretty late.
布莱恩说，独立后，爱尔兰经济仍在遭受几个世纪殖民统治的余波冲击，当时爱尔兰的主要任务就是为英国生产牲畜和农作物。英国人一直在积极打压任何爱尔兰本土工业，以防产生竞争。因此，直到20世纪，当欧洲大部分地区正忙于城市化和工业化时，爱尔兰仍然是一个主要依靠农业的国家，除了食品几乎不出口什么。比如在20世纪50年代，世界上大约有40%到50%的份额将参与农业，或者说是畜牧企业。哇，那挺晚的。
That's a late developing country. But Ireland had a second problem keeping it from looking more like its European neighbors. There just weren't that many Irish people around. Thanks to another legacy of colonization, famine. The great Irish famine of the 1840s was set in motion by a potato blight. But British economic policies made it far worse, decimating communities like those found around the Shannon estuary. In a country of 8 million, it killed every 8th person and triggered a massive wave of
这是一个发展滞后的国家。但爱尔兰还有第二个问题，使其看起来不像其欧洲邻国。这里根本没有那么多的爱尔兰人口。这要归咎于殖民统治的另一个遗毒——饥荒。19世纪40年代的大爱尔兰饥荒是由马铃薯晚疫病引发的。但英国的经济政策使其变得更加糟糕，摧毁了香农河口周围等地的社区。在一个拥有800万人口的国家里，它夺走了每八个人中一个人的生命，并引发了大规模的
emigration. every eighth person and triggered a massive wave of immigration. They say that a million died and made an emigrator and by the 1950s the population was only three million so it was a catastrophic experience. So these problems, the colonization, the rural poverty, the mass emigration, Brian says they did more than just to press the country's economy. Those were realities, and they would have given rise to a mindset that the Irish-Torsten class citizens, and that field would have persisted
移民潮。据称有一百万人死亡，还有人被迫移居海外，到了20世纪50年代，人口只剩下三百万，所以这是一次灾难性的经历。布莱恩说，这些问题——殖民统治、农村贫困、大规模移民——不仅仅是压垮了国家的经济。这些都是现实存在的，它们会催生出一种心态，即爱尔兰人是二等公民，这种感觉一直持续了下来，
right through, right up to the 1950s and 1960s. Almost a belief that the Irish could not do it as well as the British. But in the 1930s, the rest of the world quickly discovered that Ireland and its west coast in particular had three crucial advantages, location, location, location. Because Western Ireland, it turned out, was the perfect place to land a plane. The real reason why Shannon is here was aircraft had limited range. Now Maloney says that in the 1930s, the very first passenger aircraft were sea planes, big clunky aluminum things with propellers. But most long-range sea planes only cared enough fuel to fly about 3,300 miles.
一直持续到20世纪50年代和60年代。几乎有一种信念，认为爱尔兰人不如英国人做得好。但在20世纪30年代，世界其他地方很快发现，爱尔兰，尤其是其西海岸，拥有三个至关重要的优势：地理位置、地理位置、地理位置。事实证明，爱尔兰西部是降落飞机的绝佳地点。香农之所以建在这里，真正的原由是飞机的航程有限。诺尔·莫洛尼说，在20世纪30年代，最早的客机是水上飞机，那是配有螺旋桨的大型笨重铝制机器。但大多数长途水上飞机只能携带足够飞行约3300英里的燃料。
The distance between London and New York was 3,400 and 60. So if you were flying from Europe to North America, our vice versa, the challenge really was fuel, so you had to have fuel, stuff. And right there on the western edge of England was this whole other country, Ireland, which was just that much closer to the American seaboard. So in 1935, the governments of the US, the UK, Canada, and the new Irish Free State agreed that all transatlantic commercial aircraft would be required to land at a Irish airport to refuel, and the location they picked for the airport was the estuary of the River Shannon.
伦敦和纽约之间的距离是3460英里。因此，如果你从欧洲飞往北美，或者反过来，真正的挑战其实是燃料，所以你必须有燃料补给。而就在英格兰西部的边缘，有这样一个完全不同的国家——爱尔兰，它距离美洲海岸线要近得多。因此，在1935年，美国、英国、加拿大和新成立的爱尔兰自由邦的政府达成协议，所有跨大西洋的商业飞机都必须降落在爱尔兰的一个机场进行加油，他们为机场选定的地点就是香农河的河口。
And if you want to fly from New York to London, you flew in New York to Newfoundland, and you stopped, then you flew in Newfoundland to Shannon for nine hours, you stopped here, and then you flew on to Southampton, and you took the train into London. The airport at Shannon was an instant success. After all, they had a captive audience. In 1945, the now fully sovereign Republic of Ireland opened a concrete runway on the other side of the estuary. And within just two years, the airport was handling up to 100,000 passengers a month.
如果你想从纽约飞往伦敦，你会从纽约飞往纽芬兰并停留，然后从纽芬兰飞往香农飞行九个小时，在这里停留，然后继续飞往南安普顿，再坐火车进入伦敦。香农的机场一炮走红。毕竟，他们拥有现成的固定客源。1945年，如今完全主权的爱尔兰共和国在河口的另一侧修建了一条混凝土跑道。仅仅两年内，该机场每月的客流量就达到了多达10万名乘客。
But there was one tiny problem early on with this whole arrangement, at least for the Irish. And it had to do with the airports restaurant and food services. Because the Irish Prime Minister and Minister of Transport noticed the food was managed by British Airways. Not exactly who you want serving the meals at your country's largest airport when you've only just finished kicking the British out. And so the message was given to the Minister of Transport. Can you find a Irishman to take this over? And the name that the ministry came up with was a 26-year-old hospitality worker named Brendan O'Regan. Brendan O'Regan was born in the nearby village of
但早期这种安排有一个小问题，至少对爱尔兰人来说是这样。这与机场的餐厅和餐饮服务有关。因为爱尔兰总理兼交通部长注意到，这里的餐饮是由英国航空公司管理的。当你刚把英国人赶走时，这可不是你想在国家最大机场提供餐食的理想人选。于是，交通部长接到了指示。你能找个爱尔兰人来接管这个吗？部门想到的名字是一个26岁的酒店业工作者，名叫布伦丹·奥雷根。布伦丹·奥雷根出生于附近的村庄
Six Mile Bridge. A town so small, it was simply named for a bridge six miles from Limerick. But O'Regan's birthplace was the only unremarkable thing about him. I don't think I've encountered anyone in my life who was as charismatic and as compelling as he was. He just had this persuasive ability to get things done. Keen O'Karel is the co-author of a biography about Brendan O'Rigan. He also worked under O'Rigan at Shannon.
西米尔布里奇。这个小镇非常小，它因距离利默里克六英里的一座桥而得名。但奥雷根的出生地是他身上唯一平庸的地方。我想我一生中从未遇到过像他那样富有个人魅力和吸引力的人。他就是有这种把事情做成的说服力。基恩·奥卡尔是布伦丹·奥雷根传记的合著者。他曾在香农奥雷根手下工作。
And he says that O'Rigan might have been a local boy, but he was also a dashing cosmopolitan. The son of a hotelier, he had trained at hotels in Switzerland and Germany, and he had brought back with him an obsession with high standards and perfect execution. So he tapped into the prosocial excellence in everything, you know? But from the beginning, Oregan understood bringing high standards to Shannon's food services wasn't just going to be about serving nice meals. We were being written off as the vanishing Irish. This is a recording of a regan taking from an oral history interview in 2004, explaining how most
他说，奥雷根虽然是个本地男孩，但也是个风度翩翩的国际化人物。作为一名酒店业老板的儿子，他曾在瑞士和德国的酒店接受过培训，并带回了对高标准和完美执行力的执着。因此，他挖掘了方方面面的专业社会卓越性，你知道的？但从一开始，奥雷根就明白，为香农的餐饮服务引入高标准不仅仅是提供美味的饭菜。“我们当时被定义为正在消亡的爱尔兰人。”这是奥雷根2004年在一场口述历史采访中的录音，解释了大多数
foreigners still thought of the Irish in the 1930s. I've got the reason, but I'm not able to use it. They're immigrants to England and to the USA. Suppose we hadn't had the chance to prove ourselves. No. No. But if those days crossing the Atlantic was a big event and big people were doing it. And these big people remember, they're just stopping over at Shannon.
外国人对20世纪30年代爱尔兰人的看法。我有理智，但我无法使用它。他们是去英国和美国的移民。假设我们没有机会证明自己。没有。没有。但在那些日子里，横渡大西洋是一件大事，而且都是大人物在做这件事。请记住，这些大人物只是在香农中转停留。
They weren't disembarking to see anything else. So the staff there came to recognize that the stream of passengers passing through, that the only impression they would get of Ireland was what they got to the channel. So the thing about standards was very important. This weird Irish, what we could do things as well are better than anywhere else. So from the moment Oregan took over the restaurant at Shannon from the British, he started adding all these little touches. He improved the decor.
他们并没有下飞机去参观其他任何东西。所以那里的工作人员逐渐意识到，源源不断过境的旅客对爱尔兰唯一的印象就是他们在香农所经历的一切。因此，关于标准的事情非常重要。这种奇怪的爱尔兰人，我们能把事情做得和别处一样好甚至更好。所以从奥雷根接管香农餐厅的那一刻起，他就开始增添所有这些精致的细节。他改善了装饰。
He dressed the wait staff in nice suits. And one day, when he saw the head chef carrying out an anador and played a food, he chided him for its lack of eye appeal. And I said, Chef, there's no IAPO. And he looked around desperately for something to give it IAPO. And apparently the head chef could sense a challenge because he quickly took the opportunity to invent a new kind of alcoholic beverage for arriving passengers. And the following day, I came into my office with coffee in a glass and white cream on
他给服务员穿上了漂亮的西服。有一天，当他看到主厨端着一盘缺乏视觉吸引力的食物走出来时，他责备了它缺乏吸引力。我说，主厨，这毫无视觉吸引力。他绝望地四处寻找能赋予它视觉吸引力的东西。显然，主厨能够感受到这是一个挑战，于是他迅速抓住机会，为抵达的乘客发明了一种新型酒精饮料。第二天，我走进办公室，手里端着一杯加了白奶油的咖啡，
top of his and said, how is that for IAP? What's that? And what that was was the first ever Irish coffee. And we offered it to people, the entrance to the restaurant. It was of course, we'd be getting famous then. By the mid-1940s, everyone agreed the food at Chanin was better in almost every way than it had been under the British. As one rave you put it, no better window dressing for Ireland could be designed than
顶部是这样的，然后说：“这个视觉吸引力怎么样？”“那是什么？”而那正是历史上第一款爱尔兰咖啡。我们在餐厅入口处向人们提供它。它当然就此成名了。到了20世纪40年代中期，大家一致认为香农的食物在几乎所有方面都比英国管理时期要好。正如一篇热情洋溢的评论所说，再没有比让乘客享用一顿爱尔兰餐更能为爱尔兰打广告的橱窗装饰了。
the impression of a passenger's probably one Irish meal. And for up to 100,000 passengers a month, that one Irish meal was delicious. So if people like Benjamin Regan would have been very important in starting to give the new assurance to Ireland, the way we can do it, that our quality can be just as good as anybody else. Now, for most people, setting up a wildly successful restaurant at 26, burnishing your country's international reputation and helping invent the Irish coffee would be a fine enough legacy. But it turned out, Brendan O'Regan was just getting
对于每月多达10万名乘客来说，那一顿爱尔兰餐是美味的。所以，像本杰明·奥雷根这样的人，在开始赋予爱尔兰新的自信方面发挥了非常重要的作用，这种自信就是我们能做到，我们的品质可以和其他任何人一样好。现在，对大多数人来说，在26岁时创办一家大获成功的餐厅，擦亮你国家的国际声誉，并协助发明爱尔兰咖啡，已经算是不错的传奇了。但事实证明，布伦丹·奥雷根才刚刚
started. In 1950, O'Regan was traveling back to Shannon from the US by ship, and on the ship there was this little shop. And when I saw the shop, I was selling jewellery free goods. Because the ship was in international waters, it was selling items without paying any government taxes and passing those savings along to passengers. Because the ship was in international waters, it was selling items without paying any government taxes, and passing those savings along to passengers. And my man said to me,
开始。1950年，奥雷根坐船从美国返回香农，船上有这样一个小商店。当我看到这家店时，它在出售免税商品。由于这艘船在国际水域，它出售商品时无需缴纳任何政府税款，并将这些节省下来的钱返还给乘客。由于这艘船在国际水域，它出售商品时无需缴纳任何政府税款，并将这些节省下来的钱返还给乘客。然后我的人对我说，
well, if they can do it, when you're crossing the sea in a bush, you surely should be able to do it when you land for the first time. Auregan realized that in a way, all of these transiting passengers in Shannon were essentially in a no-man's land, somewhat akin to international waters. They had left their starting port, but they had not yet arrived at their final destination.
好吧，如果他们能在你坐船跨海时做到这一点，当你第一次着陆时，你肯定也应该能做到。奥雷根意识到，在某种程度上，香农所有这些中转的乘客基本上都处于一个三不管地带，有点类似于国际水域。他们已经离开了出发港，但尚未到达最终目的地。
So, O'Regan reached out to his government connections and pitched them a new idea. A government-owned operation that, just like with the restaurant, he would run in exchange for a fixed salary and a percentage of the profits. The government passed a special legislation applying purely to the airport terminal building where goods could be sold free of duty to passengers in transit. Which is how, in 1950, in a move that has to go down as one of the most pivotal moments in airport retail history, O'Reagan opened up the world's first airport-based duty-free shop. Located in a small space at the entrance to the main lounge,
因此，奥雷根联系了他在政府中的人脉，向他们推销了一个新想法。一个由政府拥有的业务，就像餐厅一样，他将以固定薪水和一定比例的利润来运营。政府通过了一项专门针对机场航站楼建筑的特殊立法，在那里可以向过境旅客免税销售商品。正因如此，在1950年，奥雷根开设了世界上第一家基于机场的免税店，这一举措注定要载入机场零售史最关键的时刻之一。位于主休息室入口处的一个小空间里，
passengers had no choice but to walk right through it. And that began the first shop, and I said, we'll begin with Irish whiskey. So people came into the lounge, and one of the early things they saw was hundreds of bottles of frisky, per se. Which in addition to being on brand was also kind of genius. Alcohol was portable, non-perishable, and normally heavily taxed.
旅客们别无选择，只能直接从里面穿过去。于是第一家店就这样开始了，我说，我们从爱尔兰威士忌开始吧。所以人们走进休息室，他们看到的最早的东西之一就是数以百计的威士忌酒瓶。这除了符合品牌定位之外，也非常天才。酒类便于携带、不易变质，而且通常税率很高。
So a bottle of your favorite whiskey that would have cost one and a half Irish pounds. At a recon store, only cost you half a pound. It was a savings of two thirds. Because it was at an airport, this would be most passengers only chance to shop there. So rather than buying just a single bottle, it actually made more sense to just go ahead and buy an even dozen. The shop soon expanded into a second area and moved way beyond just offering alcohol. So what sort of things were being sold? All kinds of Irish products, Nishidjumpers and caps.
所以你最喜欢的一瓶威士忌如果原先要花费一个半爱尔兰镑。在奥雷根的店里，只需要半英镑。节省了三分之二。因为是在机场，这将是大多数乘客唯一可以在那里购物的机会。因此，与其只买单瓶，不如直接买一打其实更合算。这家店很快扩展到了第二个区域，并远远超出了仅提供酒精饮品的范围。那么都在卖什么样东西呢？各种爱尔兰产品，呢绒套头衫和帽子。
The M. Skelly worked there in the 1950s, only a few years after it opened. And then the best of Europe, so we had watches and clocks and in jewelry and then souvenirs of Ireland and all the descriptions. Here in the internationally famous duty-free shop, transit passengers from all over the world enjoy shopping in this unusual and exciting place, a sort of fairy land into which they wonder as soon as they leave their planes
M·斯凯利于20世纪50年代在那里工作，就在开业几年后。还有欧洲最好的商品，所以我们有手表、时钟和珠宝，然后是各种描述的爱尔兰纪念品。在这里，闻名国际的免税店里，来自世界各地的过境旅客喜欢在这个不寻常且令人兴奋的地方购物，这是一种他们一离开飞机就会误入的童话般的仙境。
during refueling stops. Fishing gear, large artworks, even chandeliers. The duty-free shop at Shannon was like a Black Friday sale. If Black Friday happened 365 days a year and could only be found in an Irish airport. As it was sometimes said, Shannon was an airport built around a shop. By the mid-1950s, the Judy free shop at Shannon was also a huge source of jobs. Hino Karel says that in a nation with mostly small businesses, this one store and this one airport was actually one of Ireland's largest employers. It was an extraordinary arrangement really. It was a one man company, but they had about
在加油停留期间。钓鱼竿、大型艺术品，甚至吊灯。香农的免税店就像是一场黑色星期五大促销。如果黑色星期五一年365天都在上演，并且只能在爱尔兰的一个机场找到的话。正如人们有时所说的那样，香农是一个围绕着商店建造的机场。到20世纪50年代中期，香农的免税店也是一个巨大的就业来源。基恩·奥卡尔说，在一个大多是小企业的国家里，这家店和这个机场实际上是爱尔兰最大的雇主之一。这真是一种非凡的安排。这是一个人的公司，但他们雇用了大约
a thousand people employed. So it was a whole industry. For six years Shannon was the only airport duty free shop in the world, but the model spread quickly from there. People from other airports came along fast to see what he was doing. He told him how to do it and they all took off and opened up in Paris and in London and everywhere else. And he was happy to tell them how to do it. Oh he was, yeah, he gave everybody free advice. Some people from Shannon, like Liam, actually went abroad and helped set up duty free shops and other airports, including in the Soviet Union.
一千人。所以这是一个完整的产业。有六年时间，香农是世界上唯一的机场免税店，但这种模式很快从那里传播开来。其他机场的人很快赶来查看他在做什么。他告诉他们怎么做，然后他们全都起飞，在巴黎、伦敦和其他所有地方开业。而且他很乐意告诉他们怎么做。哦，他会的，是的，他给每个人提供免费建议。香农的一些人，比如利亚姆，实际上出国帮助在其他机场建立免税店，包括在苏联。
I set up duty free in Moscow, and then we went up to St. Petersburg, or Leningrad, and then we decided to have one and a Russian-finished border, a duty free up there. or Leningrad, and then we decided to have one on the Russian finish border. A duty free up there. Within a few decades, duty free became a thing that just exists, practically in every airport in the world, from Abu Dhabi to Bangkok. Even now, these shops are based on the same basic model that was pioneered by Brennan O'Rigan and Shannon.
我在莫斯科设立了免税店，然后我们去了圣彼得堡，或者说列宁格勒，然后我们决定在俄芬边境开一家，那里的免税店。或者说列宁格勒，然后我们决定在俄芬边境开一家。那里的免税店。在短短几十年里，免税店变成了一种普遍存在的事物，几乎存在于世界上每一个机场，从阿布扎比到曼谷。即使在今天，这些店铺仍然基于由布伦丹·奥雷根在香农开创的基本模式。
But then in the late 1950s, a leap in aviation technology threatened to undermine everything that O'Regan and his team at Shannon had built. The jet age is now here. The first American commercial jet capable of economical transatlantic service. Jet passenger aircraft were faster, lighter, and critically could fly much further without having to stop for fuel, meaning airports like Shannon weren't needed anymore.
但随后在20世纪50年代末，航空技术的飞跃威胁到了奥雷根和他在香农的团队所建立的一切。喷气式客机时代现在来临了。第一架能够提供经济实惠的跨大西洋服务的美国商业喷气式飞机。喷气式客机速度更快、更轻，最重要的是，飞行距离可以更远，无需中途停留加油，这意味着像香农这样的机场不再那么必要了。
New York, to London. In the same time that it takes you to go and see a baseball double head-up, six and a half magic hours. Flight range, the very thing that created the airport, was about to render it obsolete. Without passengers, an airport cannot survive. it has no functions, and Shannon has had a great passenger problem in recent years. Starting in 1958, the same year Boeing's first mass-produced passenger jet went into service, passenger traffic at Shannon began to plummet. And I got to say, of all the tape I listened to of Brennan Oregan, this was the one moment
纽约到伦敦。只需花你看一场棒球双重赛的时间，六个半神奇的飞行小时。航程，这个创造了机场的事物，即将使其过时。没有乘客，机场就无法生存。它没有任何功能，而且香农近年来遇到了巨大的乘客问题。从1958年开始，也就是波音第一架批量生产的喷气式客机投入运营的同一年，香农的客流量开始骤降。我必须说，在我听过的所有布伦丹·奥雷根的录音中，这是整个事件中唯一一个时刻，
in the whole saga, when looking back, he sounds genuinely rattled. There was a continuous word being passed on. We're going to lose this. I mean, they're going to overflare us, for sure they're going to overflare. But Brennan Oregan, whose initials, B-O-R, were sometimes said to stand for Bashan Ricardless, wasn't about to give up. Because I was thinking in terms of finding a way of stopping a Tarosan people from being redundant.
在回首往事时，他听起来确实感到惊慌失措。当时有源源不断的消息传进来。我们要失去这个了。我的意思是，他们肯定会飞越我们，他们一定会飞过去。但布伦丹·奥雷根的名字缩写B-O-R有时被认为代表着“无论如何都要香农”（Bashan Ricardless），他并不打算放弃。因为我在考虑如何找到一种方法，阻止爱尔兰人变得多余。
So if O'Rig is word of the time, was the aircraft dropped there and they won't come down, let's reach up and drag them down. In the idea O'Rigan and his team came came up with would take the concept of duty-free and apply it to way more than just a few stores at an airport. O'Rigen had seen something similar to the duty-free shop in Panama called a free port. A small area near the canal where ships could load and unload goods without paying customs. So why not create something similar to a free port near Shannon, not aimed at attracting consumers, but something else Ireland desperately needed. Industry.
所以如果奥雷根当时听到的话是飞机从那里飞过而不降落，那就让我们伸手把它们拉下来吧。奥雷根和他的团队想出的主意是将免税的概念应用到不仅仅是机场的几家商店。奥雷根曾在巴拿马见过类似于免税店的东西，叫做自由港。运河附近的一个小区域，船只可以在那里装卸货物而无需缴纳关税。那么，为什么不在香农附近创建一个类似于自由港的地方，不是为了吸引消费者，而是为了爱尔兰迫切需要的其他东西。工业。
In 1959, Oregan made another pitch to his connections in the Irish government. In this time, he got permission to put a fence around an area right beside the airport, cross the fence, and you'd be subjected to normal import taxes. But stay inside the fence, explain Sqenocarole, and you were officially inside the Shannon
1959年，奥雷根向他在爱尔兰政府的人脉提出了另一个建议。这一次，他获得了在机场旁边的区域周围建起栅栏的许可，跨过栅栏，你将需要缴纳正常的进口税。但留在栅栏里面，基恩·奥卡尔解释说，你就正式进入了香农
Industrial Free Zone. A place where companies could fly in parts, assemble them in factories, sapped with Irish workers, and then fly out finished products, tax-free. So the industrial free zone was a variation on the team of the Junction Free Shop. The only difference was that raw materials
工业自由区。一个公司可以空运零件进来，在工厂里由爱尔兰工人组装，然后将成品空运出去，完全免税的地方。因此，工业自由区是免税店主题的一个变体。唯一的区别是
could be brought in and processed and then exported with the absolute minimum of any customs formalities. Today customs free zones can be controversial, something we will be getting to. But back then, Oregan's idea wasn't controversial, so much as experimental. In the 1950s, the economic miracle of the duty free shop still didn't expand much beyond the airport.
原材料可以被带进来加工，然后以绝对最少的任何海关手续进行出口。如今，海关自由区可能会引起争议，这是我们接下来会谈到的。但在当时，奥雷根的想法与其说是充满争议，不如说是具有实验性。在20世纪50年代，免税店的经济奇迹仍然没有扩展到机场之外。
Ireland remained a poor, largely agricultural country. And the government's approach for years had been steeped taxes on imports. It was a way to protect what little industry Ireland did have, hoping it would eventually make stuff the rest of the world wanted. The government was ready to try something new, but Oregans industrial free zone in which any company from any country could come and make anything to be sent anywhere. Well, that was seen by many as a kind of weird long shot. And there was a lot of cynicism about it, really, like, would the industries come, would it be viable,
爱尔兰仍然是一个贫穷的、主要依靠农业的国家。政府多年来的做法一直是征收进口税。这是一种保护爱尔兰仅有的一点工业的方式，希望它最终能生产出世界其他地方想要的东西。政府已经准备好尝试新事物，但奥雷根的工业自由区——任何国家、任何公司都可以在这里来制造任何东西并运往任何地方——在许多人看来，这是一种奇怪的冒险尝试。当时对此有很多冷嘲热讽，真的，比如，工业会来吗？它能维持下去吗？
would it work? But I felt if we didn't start with something we would never start. So we took a risk. In the ultimate, if you build it, they will come approach with no committed clients. Oregans team started to erect empty factory buildings in the zone, ready for occupancy, and used them to convince companies to set up shop. And once one or two companies came, it then provides an example for other companies. And starting really from the 1960s to everyone's surprise really, the industrial estate was developing quite well. At first, it was mostly smaller American companies that came. For them, Shannon was a convenient foothold into Europe.
它能行得通吗？但我感觉如果我们不从某事开始，我们就永远不会开始。所以我们冒险了。采取了“如果你建造了它，他们就会来”的终极方针，在没有承诺客户的情况下。奥雷根的团队开始在区内竖起空的厂房，准备好入住，并用它们来劝说公司建立店面。一旦一两家公司来了，它就会为其他公司提供一个榜样。从20世纪60年代开始，出乎所有人的意料，工业园区发展得相当不错。起初，来的大多是较小的美国公司。对他们来说，香农是一个进入欧洲的便利桥头堡。
They were followed by big multinationals, like GE, to beers, and a young Japanese firm called Sony. But there were also companies with more specialized products. This is a corner of the Ripon Piano Factory at Shannon Airport, Crown to Claire, turning out something like 3,000 pianos a year. By the mid-60s, freight coming in and out of the free zone accounted for the majority of Shannon's flights.
随后是大型跨国公司，如通用电气、戴比尔斯，以及一家名为索尼的年轻日本公司。但也有拥有更专业产品的公司。这是香农机场里蓬钢琴厂的一个角落，位于克莱尔，每年生产大约3000架钢琴。到60年代中期，进出自由区的货运量占了香农航班的大多数。
Once again, the airport and the surrounding area was booming. In a very few years, over 2,000 jobs have been created, producing a wide range of products for firms whose headquarters are in countries as far apart as Holland and Japan. And flowing from the increased employment, there are great economic benefits to the whole hinterland of Shannon. After years of stagnation, Ireland's economy was beginning to grow and industrialize, and Shannon had a not insignificant part to play in that transformation. In fact, by the middle 1960s, something like 25% of Irish industrial exports were coming out of the Sharnan industrial zone. It was also in the 1960s that Ireland's centuries-long trend of immigration finally started to reverse.
机场及周边地区再次迎来了大繁荣。在短短几年内，已经创造了20,000个就业岗位，为总部远在荷兰和日本等国家的企业生产各种各样的产品。随着就业增加，香农的整个腹地也带来了巨大的经济效益。经过多年的停滞，爱尔兰经济开始增长和工业化，香农在这一转型中发挥了不容忽视的作用。事实上，到20世纪60年代中期，爱尔兰大约25%的工业出口都来自香农工业区。也正是在20世纪60年代，爱尔兰长达几个世纪的移民趋势终于开始逆转。
Many Irish immigrants and their descendants were now moving back to Ireland, and one of the places they were moving to was Shannon. So to see the returning immigrants coming back in the 1960s was a new thing, and Shannon was one of the leaders of that. But remember, the airport and its industrial zone were in the middle of nowhere. There was no place to live called Shannon, and all those returning workers needed accommodations. That was actually one of Keen O'Krell's main jobs, getting everyone housed. There were 137 apartments built, but there was nothing else.
许多爱尔兰移民及其后代现在正搬回爱尔兰，他们搬去的地方之一就是香农。因此，看到回归的移民在20世纪60年代返回是一件新鲜事，而香农就是其中的领头羊之一。但请记住，机场及其工业区地处偏僻。没有一个叫香农的地方供人居住，而所有这些回流的工人都需要住所。这实际上是基恩·奥卡尔的主要工作之一，为每个人解决住房问题。建了137套公寓，但除此之外什么都没有。
So all of the industrialists there would be complaining about the lack of facilities. Such as what sort of facilities? They complained, say, about where do they buy their groceries, and the schools weren't there, and there was no library in the place, and there wasn't even a resident doctor. And thereafter we were building a town, and of course there hadn't been built a town in Ireland since the day in the South I think as far as we go. And Oregon isn't joking there. The village of Shannon was Ireland's first new town in hundreds of years.
因此，那里的所有实业家都会抱怨缺乏设施。比如什么样的设施？他们抱怨，比如说，去哪里买食品杂货，学校不在那里，地方上没有图书馆，甚至没有常驻医生。在那之后，我们正在建设一个城镇，当然，我想自南方那一天以来，爱尔兰还没有建设过城镇。奥雷根在那里可不是在开玩笑。香农村是爱尔兰数百年来第一个新城镇。
Now again, you would think, setting up a wild, successful restaurant, branching your country's reputation, helping invent Irish coffee, jumpstarting the economy, attracting back emigrants and founding your nation's first new town in centuries would be a good place for Brendan O'Rigan to stop. But no, he wasn't done. In many ways, Shannon's industrial free zone anticipated the low tax, free market, global economy of the 1980s. But at the time, O'Rigan viewed the entire Shannon experiment in explicitly anti-colonial terms. Because I could see that our poverty had come from the fact that Britain had stopped as really from industrializing. And Eriegen became convinced that the best way
现在同样地，你可能会认为，创办一家大获成功的餐厅，为国家的声誉添砖加瓦，协助发明爱尔兰咖啡，重启经济，吸引移民回流，并建立你的国家几个世纪以来的第一个新城镇，将是布伦丹·奥雷根停下来的好地方。但没有，他还没有结束。在许多方面，香农的工业自由区预示着20世纪80年代低税收、自由市场、全球化的经济。但当时，奥雷根是以明确的反殖民主义条款来看待整个香农实验的。因为我可以看到，我们的贫困来自于英国阻止我们真正实现工业化这一事实。奥雷根坚信，其他发展中国家对抗殖民主义的最好方式
for other developing countries to fight colonialism was capitalism. I taught particularly in third-worlder situations was a requirement of every country to help those that were down. So I was very involved in the idea that the Shannon zone should be duplicated all over the world on a big scale. Starting in the mid-1960s, Oregan began spreading the gospel of industrial free zones as a path toward economic independence. In 1966, after consulting closely with Oregan, the Taiwanese government opened their first free zone at Gaushan Harbor. And in 1972, with UN funding, Shannin began offering multi-week training courses where foreign officials could learn how to set up their own zones, now called special economic zones or S.E.Z.s, based largely on
是资本主义。我特别认为在第三世界的情况下，每个国家都有必要帮助那些落后的国家。所以我非常投入于这样一个想法：香农区应该在大规模上在世界各地复制。从20世纪60年代中期开始，奥雷根开始传播工业自由区作为通往经济独立之路的福音。1966年，在与奥雷根密切协商后，台湾当局在高雄港开设了他们的第一个自由区。1972年，在联合国资金的支持下，香农开始提供数周的培训课程，外国官员可以在那里学习如何建立自己的园区，现在被称为经济特区或S.E.Z.s，主要基于
the Shannon model. Brian Kellenen taught many of these courses. And how many countries do you think passed through here? Oh, I was there roughly 20 or 30, I think. Columbia, Sri Lanka, Egypt, Indonesia, Mexico, Nigeria, Ghana. But there's one visit in particular that has since taken on almost folkloric status. In 1980, a Chinese delegation led by future President Zhang Zemin embarked on a 40-day world tour of various special economic zones, and at the end of that trip, they came to study
香农模式。布莱恩·卡拉南教授了其中许多课程。你认为有多少国家从这里经过？哦，我大概在那里接待了20或30个国家，我想。哥伦比亚、斯里兰卡、埃及、印度尼西亚、墨西哥、尼日利亚、加纳。但有一次访问尤其具有了几乎堪称民俗的地位。1980年，由时任副总理江泽民率领的中国代表团开启了对各大经济特区的40天世界之旅，在行程结束时，他们来到香农向布莱恩学习，在那里他们被带到了一个当地地标的顶端。
with Brian at Shannon, where they were taken to the top of a local landmark. Tully Glass Hill had a panoramic vista where they could take in the airport, the industrial state, and the town and as they stood there, Zhang Zemin reportedly said, this is our solution, we'll build a hundred of these in China. Do you mind if we just get off? I'm just curious to have a view of. Yeah. I went to the hill with Brian when I was in town, and I was actually kind of surprised. It's a tiny, unassuming hill lined with suburban houses.
图利格拉斯山拥有全景视野，他们可以在那里俯瞰机场、工业园区和城镇，当他们站在那里时，据报道江泽民说：“这是我们的解决方案，我们将在中国建立一百个这样的地方。”你介意我们下去吗？我只是好奇想看看风景。好的。我在镇上时和布莱恩一起去了那座山，我其实有点惊讶。这是一座不起眼的小山，两旁排列着郊区住宅。
Not exactly the kind of spot you'd expect to feature in the story of China's Meteor Grise. And nowadays, when you go to the top, trees mostly obscure the view. Okay, I guess we can see one building over there. Yes, we can see the industrial zone. Okay, one of the trees there is the airport. Okay, so this is where it brings it all together here. So this is like the stimulator. The Chinese movement into the prime sector. Yeah, this is a place. That same year, the Chinese government would set up not one, but four special economic zones. And the fact that it happened in the same year, I think it was not a co-efficient dental coexistence, right?
这并不是你期望在中国崛起的故事中出现的那种地方。如今，当你走到山顶时，树木大多挡住了视线。好吧，我想我们能看到那边的一栋建筑。是的，我们可以看到工业区。好的，那里的树木之一就是机场。好的，所以这就是它把所有这些东西汇集在一起的地方。所以这就像是一个模拟器。中国向黄金行业的迈进。是的，就是这个地方。同年，中国政府将建立的不是一个，而是四个经济特区。而且它发生在同一年这一事实，我认为这不是一个巧合的共存，对吧？
Chaoming Chen is the professor of urban sociology at Trinity College in Connecticut. And Chen says that starting in 1980, the Chinese took all of the techniques used at Shannon and began applying them at a Prometheus scale. Perhaps no one more so than what has since become the world's most famous S.E.Z. Shen Zhen. Unlike Shannon, the S.E.Z at Chen Zhen was set up right across from one of the richest cities in the world, Hong Kong. And while Shannon's Free Zone was 2.5 km2, Shen Jens was more than 300 km2. So compare that to Shen and their rise or work, there now we're talking about apples
陈晓明是康涅狄格州三一学院的城市社会学教授。陈说，从1980年开始，中国采用了香农使用的所有技术，并开始以普罗米修斯式的规模应用它们。也许没有人比后来成为世界上最著名的经济特区——深圳——更能体现这一点了。与香农不同，深圳的经济特区建立在世界上最富有的城市之一香港的对面。虽然香农的自由区面积为2.5平方公里，但深圳的面积超过了300平方公里。所以把这个跟香农相比，他们的崛起或工作，现在我们在谈论的是苹果
and oranges, right? Very quickly. Nevertheless, the core idea is, the duty free, low taxes, or taxing assumptions. Although things were pretty much the same, even the fence that went around it. So Shen then obviously was part of that being for it. Soon, this standard SZ model became a major driver of the Chinese economy. By 1984, they had already opened up 14 more. How many special economic zones are there in China today? Was that like an appropriate question? Well, depending on how
和橘子，对吧？非常快。尽管如此，核心理念是，免税、低税或税收减免。尽管事情几乎是一样的，甚至连围着它的栅栏也是如此。所以深圳显然是该计划的一部分。很快，这种标准的经济特区模式成为了中国经济的主要驱动力。到1984年，他们已经开放了另外14个。今天中国有多少个经济特区？这是一个合适的问题吗？嗯，这取决于你怎么
you count, right? I always say, you know, easily a couple of, of fouls. Some of these zones might be only a few hundred acres. Others are the sonnest of a small province. But in one way or another, they're all S.E.Z.s, and as for the most famous S.E.Z of all. The Shenzhen S.E.Z. continued to expect to a city, and that ultimately became a mega-city with over 20 million people. Xiaoming is quick to stress that not all the credit for China's S.E.Z.s can go to Shannon. There were the examples provided by Taiwan and British Hong Kong, which also operated
数，对吧？我总是说，你知道，轻轻松松几千个。其中一些园区可能只有几百英亩。其他的则是一个小省份的规模。但不管用什么方式，它们都是经济特区，至于最著名的经济特区。深圳经济特区继续向城市扩展，并最终成为一个拥有2,000多万人口的大都市。晓明很快强调，中国经济特区不能把所有的功劳都归功于香农。还有台湾和英国香港提供的榜样，它们也作为
as a customs free port. And the Chinese came up with lots of their own ideas. But if you doubt Shannon's role in all this, just take a look at the Chinese leadership's travel identity. In multi-bases, I thought weekly bases I would have delegated from China. Vincent Kunnan was the CEO of Shannon Development about a decade ago, and meeting with Chinese dignitaries was a surprisingly big part of his job. On a weekly basis, nearly weekly, and in the may instance, the biggest digager, of course,
免税港运营。而且中国人想出了很多他们自己的想法。但如果你怀疑香农在这一切中的角色，只要看一看中国领导层的旅行身份就知道了。在许多基数上，我想每周基数我都会接待来自中国的代表团。文森·库南大约十年前担任香农开发公司的首席执行官，与中国政要会面是他工作中惊人地重要的一部分。每周一次，几乎每周一次，在许多情况下，最重要的贵宾当然
was Xi Jinping. The Vice President of China Xi Jinping has arrived in Ireland for a three-day visit. Beijing Ping. In 2012, current Chinese president Xi Jinping was about to take over power, and won on a three-consonant coming out tour of sorts. And on his European leg, where did he go? Not to Brussels, not to Berlin, not to London, but Shannon. Earlier, the man who will soon take over at the helm of the world's second-largest economy landed at Shannon Airport for a stop of visit to Shannon development, which has strong
是习近平。中国副主席习近平已抵达爱尔兰进行为期三天的访问。习近平。2012年，现任中国最高领导人习近平即将接掌权力，并进行了一次某种意义上的三洲亮相之旅。在欧洲这一站，他去了哪里？不是布鲁塞尔，不是柏林，不是伦敦，而是香农。此前，即将掌舵世界第二大经济体的人降落在香农机场，对香农开发公司进行停留访问，该公司与中国有着密切的
links with China. But the main point of his visit was a key ensemblism. The main point of his visit was by going to the place where it all started. Did he mention or did Brendan O'Rigan's name come up? Did he seem to know who that was? Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. They're very conscious of the history.
联系。但他访问的重点是一次关键的聚会。他访问的重点是去一切开始的地方。他提到了吗？布伦丹·奥雷根的名字提到了吗？他似乎知道那是谁吗？哦，是的。是的，是的，是的。他们对历史非常清楚。
On the second day of his visit, she went to Six Mile Bridge. The tiny town where Brendan O'Rigan was born. Today, according to the UN, there are nearly 5,400 S.E.S. and more than 100 countries. More than 1,000 of which were established in the last 5 years. The Shannon Industrial Zone is still around, but it's no longer special. The fence is gone, and since 2005, so too are the special tax breaks. They aren't possible anymore inside the European Union. But Shannon has still had an outsized influence on Ireland itself.
在他访问的第二天，习近平去了西米尔布里奇。布伦丹·奥雷根出生的那个小镇。今天，据联合国称，有近5400个经济特区分布在100多个国家。其中有一千多个是在过去5年内建立的。香农工业区依然存在，但它不再特殊。栅栏已经消失，自2005年以来，特别税收减免也随之消失了。在欧盟内部，这些已经不再可能了。但香农对爱尔兰本身仍然产生了超乎寻常的影响。
The country's taxes are some of the lowest in the EU, with a comparatively deregulated economy focused on international investment. Qualities credited with both the Celtic Tiger of the 1990s and 2000s, but also Ireland's record economic slump after the Great Recession. So, for better or worse, while Shannon moved towards the Irish model, the rest of Ireland also moved towards Shannon. Brendan O'Rigan died in 2008 at the age of 90, but his legacy goes beyond his contribution to Ireland's economic development. Listening to those oral histories,
该国的税率属于欧盟最低之列，其经济相对放松管制，侧重于国际投资。这些特质既造就了二十世纪九十年代和二十年代的“凯尔特之虎”，也导致了爱尔兰在大衰退后创纪录的经济低迷。因此，无论好坏，当香农转向爱尔兰模式时，爱尔兰其余地区也转向了香农。布伦丹·奥雷根于2008年去世，享年90岁，但他的遗产不仅限于他对爱尔兰经济发展的贡献。听着那些口述历史，
you cut the sense that O' a Reagan's real goal was something at once simpler and more complicated. Pride. I have a great regard for the English. I married one of them. I mean, that situation where we took over from them and did best what they were doing. It was a great spiritual uplift. I continued for the Irish.
你会感觉到奥雷根真正的目标其实是一种既更简单又更复杂的东西——尊严。我非常尊敬英国人。我娶了一个英国人。我的意思是，我们在他们撤出后接手并把他们正在做的事情做到最好，那种情况。这给爱尔兰人带来了一次巨大的精神振奋。我为爱尔兰人将这种精神延续了下去。
And then we knew that we were as good as those who were empire-billsers. That we were as good as them. Speaking of Irish quality, back that shop in Shannon, there's still the small matter of my invoice for the whiskey. Oh yeah, that's right, how much? We've a tealing 32-year-old whiskey limited edition and that's only 2000 euro if you like some of that. Yeah, that would be great.
然后我们知道，我们和那些建立帝国的人一样优秀。我们和他们一样优秀。说到爱尔兰的品质，回到香农的那家商店，我买威士忌的发票还有一个小问题。哦，对了，多少钱？我们有一款限量版的帝霖32年威士忌，如果你喜欢的话，只要2000欧元。好的，那太棒了。
Can we do that? Yeah, I'll bring it around. Just kidding. I got a very sensible bottle from a nearby distillery. It was 50 euros. Alright, I suppose we can pay for that. It is after all. Duty free.
我们能买吗？可以，我会把它带过来。开个玩笑。我在附近的酿酒厂买了一瓶很实惠的。只要50欧元。好吧，我想我们可以付得起这个。毕竟，这是免税的。
When we come back, a look at the downside and sometimes very dark side of S.E.Z.s throughout the world. After this. So I'm here with Kevin Caner, who produced that story. You just heard about Shannon. And Kevin, you know, we talked about both the spread and the success of special economic zones outside of Shannon, but I know that the impact and legacy of these SCZs is really messy. Hi, Robin. Yeah, I mean, one thing we can
广告之后，我们将带您了解全球经济特区（S.E.Z.）的消极面，甚至是极其黑暗的一面。广告之后见。我是凯文·凯纳，制作了刚才你听到的关于香农的故事。凯文，你知道的，我们讨论了香农以外经济特区的普及和成功，但我知道这些经济特区的影响和遗留问题其实非常混乱。嗨，罗曼。是的，我的意思是，有一件事我们可以
say right off the bat is that there are thousands of SCZs scattered throughout the world. You know, they very drastically in size outcomes and occasionally in what exactly makes the zone special to begin with. So with that in mind, I'm going to walk you through some of the more general criticisms and big picture questions around these zones. Great. Okay, let's do it. So I'll start with one major critique, labor. In most zones, there is definitely less labor rights.
首先明确的是，世界各地散落着数千个经济特区。你知道，它们在规模、成果上差异巨大，有时甚至在究竟是什么让这个特区变得“特别”这一点上也各不相同。因此，带着这一点，我将带大家了解围绕这些特区的一些更普遍的批评和宏观问题。太好了，好的，我们开始吧。那我先从一个主要的批评开始——劳工。在大多数特区，劳工权利绝对较少。
This is Patrick Nevelling. He's a political economist I spoke with, and Patrick paints a pretty bleak picture of S.E.Z.s. He says that for the companies who operate inside some special economic zones, the poor labor rates are not a flaw, but a feature. They're basically designed to kind of destroy bargaining power, collective rights,
这是帕特里克·内韦ling。他是我采访过的一位政治经济学家，帕特里克对经济特区描绘了一幅相当黯淡的画面。他说，对于在某些经济特区内运营的公司来说，糟糕的劳工待遇并不是一个瑕疵，而是一个特色。它们基本上旨在摧毁发展中国家工人的谈判能力、集体权利、
movements of workers in developing nations and create one could say rights-free zones, where a capital can freely run riots against war-cuss rights. And this happens partly because when a new zone is being set up, the power dynamic tilts towards the businesses and corporations that the zone is trying to attract. So if a government can help entice a company to its new zone by offering less labor protections or less red tape, then some unfortunately are tempted to do just that.
工人运动，并可以称之为创造了“无权利特区”，资本可以在这里肆意践踏工人的权利。这种情况发生的部分原因是，当一个新特区建立时，权力天平会向特区试图吸引的企业倾斜。因此，如果一个政府能够通过提供较少的劳动保护或较少的繁文缛节来吸引公司来到其新特区，那么不幸的是，一些政府就会忍不住这么做。
So did Patrick have some examples of what he was talking about where you can find these labor issues and labor exploitation playing out? Yeah, so when it actually is from Shen Zhen, the Chinese SEC that we mentioned in the main piece, which opened in 1980, and which has really become the world's most famous SEC. I mean, you will remember the kind of images which opened in 1980 and which has really become the world's most famous S.E.Z.
那么，帕特里克有没有举出一些例子，说明你所说的这些劳工问题和劳工剥削是如何上演的呢？是的，其中一个例子实际上来自深圳，这是我们在主体部分提到的中国经济特区，它于1980年开放，并且确实已成为世界上最著名的经济特区。我的意思是，你会记得那种在1980年开放的画面，它确实已成为世界上最著名的经济特区。
I mean you will remember the kind of images of the Foxconn factory in Chenzhen where they had this netting around the dormitories and the factory buildings so that people couldn't successfully commit suicide anymore. Patrick is referring to these nets that were put up in 2010 around Foxconn factory buildings in Chenzhen after a disturbing spate of suicides. These factory workers who were in part Patrick is referring to these nets that were put up in 2010 around Foxconn factory buildings in Chenn-Gene after a disturbing spate of suicides. These factory workers who were in part producing Apple products were regularly forced to work inhumane hours for minimal pay. And Patrick says that Foxconn in Chenn-Gene is far from the only example of traveling labor practices in special economic zones. We are talking about the Marquilas, under Mexican U.S. border. We are talking about the Makila, under Mexican-US border.
我的意思是，你会记得深圳富士康工厂的那种画面，他们的宿舍和厂房周围围着网，这样人们就再也不能成功自杀跳楼了。帕特里克指的是2010年在深圳富士康厂房周围安装的这些网，当时发生了一连串令人不安的自杀事件。部分生产苹果产品的工厂工人帕特里克指的是2010年在深圳富士康厂房周围安装的这些网，当时发生了一连串令人不安的自杀事件。部分生产苹果产品的工厂工人定期被迫以微薄的报酬进行不人道的工作时长。帕特里克说，深圳的富士康绝不是经济特区中糟糕劳工做法的唯一例子。我们说的是墨西哥和美国边境的马奎拉多拉工厂。我们说的是墨西哥和美国边境的马奎拉多拉工厂。
We are talking about the ready-made government in St. Bangladesh. We are talking about workers assembling furniture for IKEA and India. So Patrick basically sees these S.E.Zs as places where capitalism has ran amok, where the rights of corporations are prioritized over the people who actually work and live in the area.
我们说的是孟加拉国的成衣厂。我们说的是在印度为宜家组装家具的工人。因此，帕特里克基本上将这些经济特区视为资本主义横行的地方，在这里，企业的权利优先于真正在该地区工作和生活的人民。
So did any of the more pro-SEZ interviewees that you talked to for this story, especially ones that were sort of enamored with the origin story of S.E.Z.s, did they have anything to say about this labor criticism? Yeah, so I spoke to Brian Callanon, he's one of the characters from the main piece who was involved in teaching the how to set up your own
那么，你为这个故事采访的那些更支持经济特区的人，尤其是那些对经济特区的起源故事着迷的人，他们对这种劳工批评有什么看法吗？是的，我和布莱恩·卡拉南谈过，他是主体部分中的人物之一，曾参与在香农向外国官员提供如何建立自己的
S.E.Z. courses that were offered in Shannon to foreign officials. And he fully acknowledges that special economic zones can have downsides. Positive outcomes have been associated with good labor rights, good skills development, good linkages, but negative outcomes have been associated with poor labor rights and in some minority cases, the regulation in the zones has given less rights to workers than in the domestic society, which really problematic. Now, Brian notes that decreased labor rights were not what their SEC workshops were advocating since and Shannon the same labor rights applied in the zone as in the rest of Ireland. But for some SECs, that's not always the case.
经济特区课程的教学。他完全承认经济特区可能有消极的一面。积极的成果与良好的劳工权利、良好的技能发展、良好的关联性联系在一起，但消极的成果则与糟糕的劳工权利联系在一起，在少数情况下，特区内的放松管制赋予工人的权利比国内社会还要少，这确实是个问题。现在，布莱恩指出，劳动权利的下降并不是他们的经济特区研讨会所倡导的，因为在香农，特区内适用的劳动权利与爱尔兰其他地区相同。但对于某些经济特区来说，情况并非总是如此。
And in some countries, labor laws are poor to begin with, which leaves a room for corporations to come in, set up shop in a low wage, low tax environment, and offer very little spill-off benefits to the local economy. So how does a country avoid getting stuck in these low wage, little return to local economy type of SEC. Well, to avoid this trap, Brian sees a big role for local government in helping to manage the
在一些国家，劳动法本来就很糟糕，这为企业提供了空间，让它们可以进入并在低工资、低税收的环境中建立业务，却为当地经济提供非常微薄的外溢效益。那么，一个国家如何才能避免陷入这种“低工资、对本地经济回报甚微”的经济特区类型呢？为了避免这个陷阱，布莱恩认为地方政府在帮助管理特区方面可以发挥重要作用，
zone and make sure that the zone is fulfilling its purpose of actually helping the wider economy. So for him, these zones are not some sort of lazy fair approach where the government just puts up a fence, lowest taxes, and leaves things to the market. And in fact, in those zones that just offer low taxes and nothing else, those zones are failures in terms of a frame for impact. What the successful zones have been, I just say, a partnership between the state and the private sector, where the state provides the centers, provides the infrastructure, but lots of the states can decide who gets into the zone and who is a right to establish there.
并确保特区正在履行其真正帮助更广泛经济的宗旨。因此，对卡拉南而言，这些特区并非某种放任自流的方法，即政府只需竖起栅栏、降低税收，然后一切交给市场。事实上，在那些只提供低税收而没有其他东西的特区里，从产生影响的框架来看，这些特区都是失败的。成功的特区，我可以说，是国家与私营部门之间的伙伴关系，国家提供中心、提供基础设施，但许多国家可以决定谁能进入特区以及谁有权在那里建立企业。
So it's very much the state being selective on what type of companies it gets in. Brian points out that in Shannon's case, there was a pretty significant outflow of skills from the zone to local Irish companies. After working in the Shannon zone for companies like Sony or GE, workers would go on to work with Irish owned companies outside of the zone and bring those skills that they learn in the zone with them. I mean, it sounds like what Brian's talking about is an idealized SEC that sounds good if it works.
因此，这非常体现国家在引进何种类型企业方面的选择性。布莱恩指出，在香农的案例中，技能从特区流向当地爱尔兰公司的规模相当可观。在索尼或通用电气等公司在香农特区工作后，工人们会前往特区外的爱尔兰本土公司工作，并将他们在特区学到的技能带过去。我的意思是，听起来布莱恩谈论的是一个理想化的经济特区，如果成功的话听起来很不错。
So what are the conditions that make a good SEC work? Well, despite the labor issues that we just talked about, I would say that the SEC approach is most useful in cases just like Ireland in the 1960s or China in the 1980s, where country with pretty little industrialization and a relatively close economy wants to test out a new approach in a small area. It allowed the receiving country the ability
那么，让一个好的经济特区发挥作用的条件是什么呢？好吧，尽管有我们刚才讨论的劳工问题，但我会说，经济特区方法在类似于20世纪60年代的爱尔兰或20世纪80年代的中国的案例中最有用，当时一个工业化程度相当低、经济相对封闭的国家希望在一个小区域内测试一种新方法。它允许接收国在选定区域内
to accept capitalism in restricted doses in selected areas, and therefore to gain benefit in those areas and to manage capitalism and structure the impact of capitalism in an organized way that possibly might maximize the benefits and minimise the costs. Because capitalism can bring suffraice of substantial costs. minimise the costs, because capitalism can bring suffraice of financial costs. Brian sees S.E.Z. as a sort of stepping stone towards industrialisation, not necessarily a final destination. For example, in China's case, if they just thrown open the floodgates to capitalism, it probably wouldn't have worked out very well, because there's no way its protected state industries would have survived a sudden onslaught of global competition,
以受控的剂量接受资本主义，从而在这些区域获得利益，并以有组织的方式管理资本主义并构建资本主义的影响，这可能最大化利益并最小化成本。因为资本主义会带来相当大的成本。最小化成本，因为资本主义会带来足够的财务成本。布莱恩将经济特区视为通往工业化的一种垫脚石，而不一定是最终目的地。例如，就中国的案例而言，如果他们只是向资本主义敞开大门，结果可能不会很好，因为其受保护的国家工业绝不可能在突如其来的全球竞争冲击下生存下来，
which is actually what happened to the industry in former communist countries, like East Germany at the end of the Cold War. Yeah. But by testing out reforms in defined zones, China was able to slowly open up to a market economy, which obviously proved very successful in the case of Shen Zhen and Chen as a whole. So you have these at least economic success stories when it comes to Shannon and Chen-Chan, despite bad labor practices potentially in these places.
这实际上就是冷战结束时前共产主义国家（如东德）工业所发生的事情。是的。但通过在明确的特区内测试改革，中国得以缓慢向市场经济开放，这在深圳以及中国整体的案例中显然被证明是非常成功的。因此，尽管这些地方可能存在糟糕的劳工做法，但在香农和深圳，你至少拥有这些经济成功的故事。
But are there certain SECs that just failed like from the get-go, like never really took off? Yeah, I mean, I looked into this and there are lots of stories of SECs not really working out. In Africa, especially the record of these SECs have not been great when looked at through metrics like employment and export figures. And one possibility of why that is is that most African countries didn't start creating special
但是，有没有某些经济特区一开始就失败了，比如从来没有真正起飞过呢？是的，我的意思是，我调查过这一点，有很多关于经济特区没有真正发挥作用的故事。在非洲，特别是通过就业和出口数字等指标来看，这些经济特区过去的表现一直不太好。造成这种情况的一个可能原因是，大多数非洲国家直到很晚才开始创建经济
economic zones until much later. So the growth and success of the zones in places like Taiwan, China, and Korea in the mid-20th century were largely driven by the incredible growth in overall global trade that occurred in the 1980s. And by the time most African zones started to be set up in the 90s, it was kind of too late. There were already so many well-established and attractive possibilities in the world where companies could set up their manufacturing options. So why choose a less established zone that's just getting going. Right. And I would imagine that because, you know, there's so many economic zones in the world that when you're competing globally, these zones kind of spark a race to the bottom in terms of taxes in these various countries. Like, many countries around the world would offer lower and lower
特区。因此，20世纪中期台湾、中国和韩国等地的特区的增长和成功，很大程度上是由20世纪80年代发生的整体全球贸易的惊人增长所推动的。到了90年代大多数非洲特区开始建立时，已经有点太晚了。世界上已经有那么多成熟且有吸引力的可能性，公司可以在那里建立他们的制造选择。那么为什么要选择一个刚刚起步、不那么成熟的特区呢。对。而且我想象，因为你知道，世界上有那么多的经济特区，当你在全球竞争时，这些特区在这些不同国家的税收方面会引发一场竞次。例如，世界上许多国家会提供越来越低的
taxes in order to compete with each other for a company's business. Right. Brian agrees with this criticism. And as he said in our first interview, while low wages and low taxes can be an important initial instrument to attract business. If they become part of the long-term strategy, they're a disaster. Because low taxes means you're not getting the revenue from enterprises to finance your own development programs. And you're not getting revenue from enterprise to financial social services, your skill development, and your public service programs. So in the longer term, it's essential you move towards a higher level of tax and a higher level of wages.
税收，以便在公司业务方面相互竞争。对。布莱恩同意这种批评。正如他在我们第一次采访中所说，虽然低工资和低税收可以成为吸引业务的重要初始工具。如果它们成为长期战略的一部分，那将是一场灾难。因为低税收意味着你无法从企业那里获得收入来资助你自己的发展计划。你无法从企业获得收入来资助社会服务、技能发展和公共服务项目。因此，从长远来看，至关重要的是转向更高水平的税收和更高水平的工资。
And that means you develop into a more sustained economy and a sustained society that can pay for itself. So low wages, low taxes, they're a kickstart, but they're not part of the long-term, permanent, strata of a country and they should never be. But what's interesting is that low taxes are in a way a legacy of the Shannon-Free Zone, because when Ireland joined the European Economic community in 1973, this is the forerunner to the EU. They were no longer allowed to offer special low taxes in the Shannon zone. And Patrick, our resident SEC skeptic from earlier, says that in order to maintain the tax incentive that Ireland was known for,
这意味着你发展成一个能够自给自足的更具可持续性的经济体和社会。因此，低工资、低税收是一个启动器，但它们不应该、也永远不应该成为一个国家长期、永久结构的一部分。但有趣的是，低税收在某种程度上是香农自由贸易区的一项遗产，因为当爱尔兰在1973年加入欧洲经济共同体（这是欧盟的前身）时，
the Irish government reviewed the national corporate tax rate and reduced it to the point that it was one of the lowest in the EU, which was fairly groundbreaking back in the day, and which kind of set the tone for this kind of race to the, you know, US companies having some kind of headquarters in Ireland that they set up at some point. Exactly. That's why Facebook is there. I think maybe LinkedIn is there. There's lots of different, especially kind of Silicon Valley type companies that have set up in Ireland exactly for this reason.
他们不再被允许在香农特区提供特殊的低税率。我们早前的常驻经济特区怀疑论者帕特里克说，为了保持爱尔兰闻名遐迩的税收激励措施，爱尔兰政府审查了国家企业税率，并将其降低到欧盟最低水平之一，这在当时相当具有开创性，并且为这种竞次定下了基调，你知道的，美国公司在爱尔兰设立某种总部，他们在某个时候建立了总部。完全正确。这就是为什么Facebook在那里的原因。我想也许LinkedIn也在那里。有很多不同种类的、特别是硅谷类型的公司正是出于这个原因在爱尔兰设立了机构。
Okay, so that gets me wondering, like, what do Brian and Patrick see as some of the other legacies of the Shannon zone for Ireland as a whole like beyond low taxes? Well, if you ask Patrick He thinks that kind of negative attitude towards regulation and taxes that Shannon helped foster He sees those things as helping artificially fuel Ireland's so-called Celtic tagger economy and the 90s and 2000s Which famously went belly up quite dramatically during the Great Recession.
好的，这让我很好奇，除了低税收之外，布莱恩和帕特里克认为香农特区对爱尔兰整体的其他遗产有哪些？好吧，如果你问帕特里克，他认为香农帮助培养的那种对监管和税收的消极态度，他认为这些东西有助于人为地推动爱尔兰在90年代和2000年代所谓的“凯尔特之虎”经济，而该经济在大衰退期间出名地急剧崩溃。
But Brian, for his part, says it's hard to make a direct cause and effect connection between the founding of the Shannon S.E.Z. and the financial crisis that happened some 50 years later. He points out that the overheated Irish economy prior to the recession was largely based on rising property prices, not trade or manufacturing. Yeah. This is definitely a case where the answer depends on who you ask.
但就布莱恩而言，他说很难在香农经济特区的建立与大约50年后发生的金融危机之间建立直接的因果关系。他指出，经济衰退前过热的爱尔兰经济主要基于不断上涨的房产价格，而不是贸易或制造业。是的。这绝对是一个答案取决于你问谁的案例。
Yeah, definitely. But interestingly, the legacy of low taxes might finally be reversing. Just a couple months ago, Ireland relented and signed on to a landmark tax agreement that will see it along with countries around the world implement a higher corporate tax rate for large corporations. And Brian Callanen thinks the agreement is a step in the right direction. I don't think Ireland has anything to fear because we are a mature, advanced country with the best technology and the best skills. And a manageable tax, reasonable tax is part of our apparatus, but only one part of our apparatus now is not even most important.
是的，绝对的。但有趣的是，低税收的遗产可能最终正在扭转。就在几个月前，爱尔兰作出妥协，签署了一项具有里程碑意义的税收协议，该协议将使爱尔兰以及世界各国的企业一起对大公司实施更高的企业税率。布莱恩·卡拉南认为该协议朝着正确的方向迈出了一步。我不认为爱尔兰有什么好怕的，因为我们是一个成熟、先进的国家，拥有最好的技术和最好的技能。可控的税收、合理的税收是我们机制的一部分，但现在只是我们机制的一部分，甚至不是最重要的一部分。
So in many ways, this is why Brian sees Shannon's legacy as being a largely positive one, because it showed Ireland a path toward becoming precisely this kind of high-skilled, high-tech, industrialized, modern country that can afford to raise taxes. Well, that's interesting. It seems like that goes back to what he said about the SEC model being a stepping stone and not an end goal.
所以在许多方面，这就是为什么布莱恩认为香农的遗产在很大程度上是积极的，因为它向爱尔兰展示了一条道路，使其成为这样一个高技能、高科技、工业化的现代化国家，能够承担得起提高税收的费用。嗯，这很有趣。这似乎回到了他之前所说的经济特区模型是一个垫脚石而不是最终目标的观点。
Like, you know, Ireland pulled that off with its SEC, even if perhaps like many other countries didn't. Yeah, exactly. Which is, while though he did agree with many of the critiques that I put to him about SECs, in the end, he really cautioned against making any kind of overgeneralization. I suppose the critiques I would not agree with would be the black and white ones saying that all zones are good or all zones are bad. You can't label all zones in any one way. Zone is a different depending on the way they're developing, it's depending on the conditions
就像，你知道的，爱尔兰通过其经济特区成功做到了这一点，即使可能像许多其他国家一样没有做到。对，完全正确。这就是为什么，虽然他同意我向他提出的关于经济特区的许多批评，但他最终确实警告不要做任何形式的过度概括。我想我不会同意的批评是那种非黑即白的批评，即说所有的特区都是好的，或者所有的特区都是坏的。你不能以任何单一的方式给所有特区贴上标签。特区根据它们的发展方式、根据
in the country itself. So each zone needs to be able to look at it in its own right. Like any policy instrument, there are strengths of their weaknesses. It's not all one single picture. And one last thing I'd love to mention is that, you know, in the case of Shannon and Shenzhen, we're looking at these zones on their spread now in terms of our 21st century thoughts and beliefs about capitalism and development. But what's interesting to me is that what came through in all the interviews I heard with Brennan O'Regan and the oral archive is that he wasn't a man who was particularly ideological. Rather, what comes through is that of a practical man
国家本身的条件而有所不同。因此，每个特区都需要能够按照其自身的情况来看待。像任何政策工具一样，它们有优势也有劣势。这并不是一幅单一的画卷。最后我想提到的一点是，你知道，在香农和深圳的案例中，我们现在是在21世纪对资本主义和发展的思想和信念的视角下来看这些特区及其普及的。但对我来说有趣的是，我在对布伦丹·奥雷根的所有采访以及口述档案中感受到的，是他并不是一个特别意识形态化的人。相反，展现出来的是一个务实的人，
thinking first in terms of saving his local region and airport and providing employment. And then later on, an approach to industrialization with these SECs that he thought would be most beneficial for alleviating poverty around the world. Here he is talking to an interviewer in the oral archive about industrialization. I feel that that's going to eventually be the thing that we remove hunger and poverty all over the world. And war will be universal with very manufacturing of some kind.
首先考虑的是拯救他的地方区域和机场并提供就业。然后，在后来，他通过这些经济特区提出了一种工业化方法，他认为这将对减轻世界各地的贫困最有益。在这里，他在口述档案中对一位采访者谈到了工业化。我觉得这最终将成为我们消除全世界饥饿和贫困的事情。而且随着某种形式的制造业的普及，战争也将是普遍的。
I don't know exactly how it will be, but it will be done anyway with machines. I think this globalizationist, the globalized economy will lead to that when it will, well, they're dangerous though. There are dangers that they grace. Lot of wisdom in the world that knows that it's wrong and it's trying to get it right. We'll get it right eventually. And as you can hear there, he's a pretty optimistic guy overall. I mean, he does seem optimistic, but he actually is more thoughtful about it than I would even anticipate given, you know, how successful he was at the time. Yeah. So what about Brendan O'Regan's legacy in Ireland? I mean, the people know how much he changed about their country. Like, is he some kind of household name? No, surprisingly not. Even in Shannon, the town he basically built among younger generations, he's in all that well-known.
我不知道具体会怎样，但无论如何它都会通过机器完成。我认为这种全球主义、全球化的经济将导致这一点，当它……不过它们很危险。它们造成的危险很大。世界上有很多智慧知道这是不对的，并且正试图把它纠正过来。我们最终会把它纠正过来的。正如你所听到的那样，他总体上是一个非常乐观的人。我的意思是，他确实显得很乐观，但考虑到他在当时取得的成功，他其实比我预期的还要深思熟虑。是的。那么布伦丹·奥雷根在爱尔兰的遗产是什么呢？我的意思是，人们知道他改变了他们国家的多少东西吗？比如，他算是一个家喻户晓的名字吗？不，出人意料的是，并不是。即使在香农，这个他基本上亲手建立的城镇里，在年轻一代中，他也不是那么广为人知。
So, for example, my friend Amanda who grew up in Shannon and first took me off to this story and the existence of the zone, she didn't know who Brennan and Reagan was. And from my time in Shannon, that seemed pretty typical. But I think for Oregan, that would have been just fine. Oregan mentioned in the oral archive that he felt far too much attention and praise went to him when so many people worked on these ideas from the restaurant and the duty free store to the Shannon free zone and were responsible for them succeeding and working. But nevertheless, it's still amazing to me how far the legacy of one person can go when the circumstances are right. Well, it's a fascinating story. Thank you so much Kevin for bringing it to us, so I appreciate it. Oh, it was my pleasure.
例如，我的朋友阿曼达在香农长大，最初把我带到了这个故事以及特区的存在，她并不知道布伦丹·奥雷根是谁。从我在香农的经历来看，这似乎很典型。但我认为对于奥雷根来说，这其实也挺好的。奥雷根在口述档案中提到，他觉得太多的关注和赞誉落在了他身上，而实际上有那么多的人为这些想法工作过，从餐馆、免税店到香农自由贸易区，他们才是一切成功和发挥作用的幕后功臣。尽管如此，当环境合适时，一个人的遗产能够走多远，对我来说仍然是惊人的。好吧，这是一个迷人的故事。非常感谢凯文给我们带来这个故事，我很感激。哦，这是我的荣幸。
Thanks for having me. 99% invisible was produced this week by Kevin Caner's. Edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mixing tech production by Dara Hirsch and Martin Gonzalez. Delaney Hall is our executive producer. Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rise of team includes Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroubaix, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemadon, Jason Dillion, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
谢谢你邀请我。本周的“99%隐形”由凯文·卡纳制作。乔·罗森伯格编辑。达拉·赫施和马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音技术制作。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的执行制作人。库尔特·科尔施塔德是数字总监。团队成员包括维维安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝克斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、拉谢马多、杰森·迪利昂、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。
Music for this episode by our director of Sound Swan Rial with Sasha Shuchek and Mickey Nilligan on fiddle. You can find more of their music at SoundCloud.com slash the Sisters' Tree Daces. Special thanks to a bunch of people in Ireland and beyond who helped us with our story this week in Ocarol, Kevin Tomstone, Valerie Sweeney, Matthew Thompson, and Amanda Kang. And additional thanks to Ken who edited the Brendan O'Regan Oral Archive used in this piece and graciously let us use it. We'll have links to his biography of Oregan as well
本集的音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里尔创作，萨莎·舒切克和小提琴手米奇·尼利根演奏。你可以在SoundCloud.com slash the Sisters' Tree Daces上找到他们的更多音乐。特别感谢爱尔兰及其他地方的一群帮助我们完成本周故事的人：奥卡罗尔、凯文·汤姆士通、瓦莱丽·斯威尼、马修·汤普森和阿曼达·康。还要感谢编辑了本文中使用的布伦丹·奥雷根口述档案并慷慨允许我们使用的肯。我们将在我们的网站上提供他的奥雷根传记链接
as Brian Callanian's History of Shannon on our website. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. Beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. This is Niner-Niner Puppy, India, clings to chair on approach to serious extreme link.
以及布莱恩·卡拉南的香农历史。我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。美丽。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我（Roman Mars）以及节目@99PI org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上也可以。你可以在99PI dot org上找到我喜爱的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI过去的每一集。这是Niner-Niner小狗，印度，在接近严肃极限的链条上抓紧椅子。
Niner-Niner Puppy, do we reach you to a new hard way from anything? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Niner-Niner小狗，我们是否以任何新方式触及了你？本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。